[Music]
one this is Kevin from the chess website
comm and today we're gonna be going over
the Scotch game or the scotch offense
kind of look at some of the key concepts
of the opening and some of the things
you should look out for when you play it
so we'll go ahead and dive in White's
first move is efore black responds be
five white develops Knight f3 black
responds knight c6 and this is a common
opening that you'll see many times and
from here most people are familiar with
the roy lopez which is the b6 with the
bishop but today we're going to be going
over the scotch game which is simply
pawn to d4
and right away you can you can see a
difference in what our strategy is we
are trying to undermine blacks inner
control this pawn we're going to open up
the center here which should give blacks
some counter play but we should we
should have a pretty good center control
as far as the d5 square with our pawn
and should have a very good game and
we're gonna go over some of the the
mainline variations so that you're
familiar with them if you you do come
across this as white or black so you can
know how to play so from here almost
always you will see black just capture
keep in mind you will see you know weak
players always do tend to mixed it
mistakes as long as as well as blitz
game so if you do see something like
pawn to you know d6 you can't always
capture and then depending on how they
capture you know if they try to capture
here if they do they're not you can
capture their Knight eventually they'll
move their pawn and you can capture
their Queen and they'll have to move
their King obviously you can look at
this and realize that this is not a very
good game for black as we're equal in
material but black can no longer castle
so if you do see them try to defend like
this go ahead and take advantage of that
but most people are not going to do that
so after black captures White's going to
just recapture with his Knight
now keep in mind black has a few options
here and we're gonna go over each own
one of the less likely scenarios is that
black just recaptures here it's probably
not a good move
white can just come in and recapture
with this Queen and the Queen's not
really develop too early a lot of the
times you can develop your queen too
early and then a knight can with a tempo
come and chase your queen away but here
the the c6 Knight would actually be the
the piece that would they would chase
our queen away black can always come
down with c5 it's not really a good move
it's blocking in his Bishop here and and
y can just bring his his queen back to
to d3 and we still have great center
control and our queen is actually in a
pretty good spot so you won't see that
one too often but the three main lines
that we're going to talk about today the
first one is just Queen to h4 you'll see
this sometimes black basically tries to
get a free pawn here and in exchange why
it's going to get rapid development and
he's going to have a very strong attack
and blacks king is going to be at a huge
weakness and we're gonna go over the the
main line of this variation real quick
white develops his knight protecting
this pawn on the e4 square and blacks
going to develop his Bishop dark square
Bishop at the be Foursquare attacking
and putting down our knight so that this
e for square is being attacked again
from this Queen but can no longer be
defended by this knight on c3 and we are
going to bring our Bishop to e2
yes our pawn is going to fall but we we
do want to castle so that our knight is
no longer pinned and after the Queen
takes then we are going to move our
knight to a nifty square of the b v
square where it can't be touched at the
same time it's threatening this c7
square this pawn cannot move and so
we're going to be taking this obviously
if the bishop can always move back but
then we can just take that piece so from
here you don't me just see the bishop
take to give white double pawns and we
will take as well and now you'll
normally see
just black move his King over he doesn't
want to lose this pawn here and then
from here watch just going to castle and
so if you look at this we are actually
down a pawn but our development is much
better and we should have a much better
game blacks King is in a very bad
position and if played correctly
we actually should win this the majority
of the time so that is one variation the
next variation we're going to go over
after this is simply f6 the development
of the Black Knight here and from here
we're just going to develop
excuse me instead we're going to just
take this knight on c6 sometimes you'll
see a development by white to the c3
square but I like to give my opponent as
many chances to make a mistake as
possible and I personally don't mind if
he takes with his C pawn and doubles up
his C and B pawns I really like playing
against that and if for any reason he
chooses to take with the D pawn which a
lot of times people make mistakes you
can like we talked about earlier come in
and capture with your queen and then he
is forced to recapture with his King and
his King can no longer castle so the
subtle things like that where if your
equal and opera equal and material and
you can force the King the black King
away from castling you should have a
very good game another variation you'll
see is Bishop to c5 and from here we're
actually going to do the exact same
thing we're just going to capture this
Knight as long as this Knights here for
the most part we're just going to to
capture it
obviously we talked about earlier if the
night captures are not what we do but
from here same thing if they try to
recapture with the pawn that is
completely okay and if they try to
recapture with this pawn again we can
always come down and take with our queen
and he's forced to recapture obviously
then we are going to develop our Bishop
and then Castle kingside and we still
have you know our Bishop can easily be
developed and our knight can easily be
developed and they're not blocked in at
all as we said earlier on it's a very
open game so both sides are not going to
be blocked in like some of the other
openings as far as your pieces so in
this type of game bishops usually fare
better because the game is open so just
keep that in mind if you have an
exchange and they are offering up their
Bishop for your night I would go ahead
and take this since bishops are gonna
play better but these are some of the
the main variations of the Scotch game
so if you're a player that normally runs
into the Roy Lopez a lot of players
study how to defend the Roy Lopez very
very well and so if you're getting into
a game and you you see the game starting
to turn towards the Roy Lopez and you
notice that your opponent seems pretty
happy about this you can always just
throw wrench in his game plan
just play d4 this scotch game and if
you're familiar with it in all the
variations of it
you should have a very good game and a
lot of times we'll just catch your
opponent off guard so hope you guys
enjoyed this video please subscribe
helps out a lot as I fell Gellin of the
videos leave me comments let you guys
let me know what you guys think of the
videos how things are going fairly no
new to YouTube only about it's only been
a few weeks now but trying to put up a
lot more videos trying to help you guys
out a lot on all the openings and then
I'm gonna kind of get into the middle
game and how to analyze a board and how
to play there in the middle of the game
and then we'll get into in game tactics
so hope I hope you guys enjoyed and I'll
see y'all next video thanks